[Music]
and you ready to rock let's do this man
the prodigal podcast son has returned my
favorite little brother the adopted
stepchild of the RRP the black sheep or
I don't know there's no no's competition
there's competition who's your
competition JJ yeah he's not well he's a
different kind of black sheep
yes he is his own he's got the the
leader of the black sheep squad but dude
it's so funny doing this because we
always like because we're both always
off doing crazy things and crazy lives
and and and we rarely do they'll like
you know oh how was your day today that
kind of checking in but I'll just show
up here randomly and then if this is
like we like lock and load into the
chamber you know well I don't know
what's gonna happen here we don't have
any agenda there's no you know there's
no specific subject matter that I feel
like we have to cover I just thought
you're you've been on the show what like
six times at this point I think I think
it's six yeah I think you I think you
have the record more than anybody else
but at the same time I don't think
you've been on the show for over a year
at least it's been a while it's yeah
it's been maybe a year and a half yeah I
think so I mean you know since the book
came out
so we're due for a check and yes and a
lot of terrain that's been covered yes
and the beautiful thing is you don't
have anything to promote yes I was
Burroughs I that was one of these I was
like this is actually the perfect time
to podcast because I have I have no
talking points I have there's nothing
that like I want to hit or out I have
nothing to plug I have you know I mean
I'm not shilling for anything for once
and we can just just throw down catch up
talk [ __ ] bust each other's balls well
you've been doing a lot of stuff but I
sort of conceptually I was doing a
little bit of thinking like okay what
you know what do I want to cover like
there should at least be you know some
overarching theme here yeah and I think
that what's interesting about you and
and maybe perhaps in part
why people connect with you when you're
on the show because these episodes are
always super popular with people is that
in certain respects you're you're in
many ways can like a stand-in for the
audience like I think your life
experience or kind of your perspective
on a lot of the things that I talk about
yeah
comes from you know a shared kind of
kind of viewpoint that a lot of people
who listen to this show harbour or have
just in terms of like okay how do I like
I like rich he talks about cool stuff
but like I don't know if I'm there yet
or I don't know how to make this work
and I'm still struggling and you've had
an interesting journey with all of these
things over the last year yeah yeah I
I'm a professional struggler I have all
the problems that the people who listen
to your podcast have and I that's your
rare you're a musician you're a writer
but but your vocation is struggling yeah
yeah I accept falling short no we talked
about this before like you're attached
to certain lifestyle habits that I've
always encouraging you to shed and
transcend and you nonetheless persistent
hanging on to its I have a hard time an
emotional hoarder I like I don't I don't
I don't really hoard stuff that mean but
I hang on to like feelings and things
you know I I I've been struggling with
sobriety I haven't I've been relapsed
but I definitely like I think about that
[ __ ] a lot and I was talking to a buddy
of mine and I was like man yeah you know
everyone said well I just I like get a
Jones where I like you know like I want
to go to the bar and do six shots and
then go blow a bunch of lines all right
hold on a second let me let me give you
his response and he just looked at me
and he was like you know that we don't
do that anymore right you know that like
you you quit but we stopped we're all 40
you know it's like even if you're not an
alcoholic or an addict like people taper
off people grow up you know
right but you so let me let's explore
that for a second here so when you have
that craving or you feel that likes for
groundswell of you know compulsiveness
rise up inside of you you're not acting
on it but
what is the what are the emotions that
you experience like do you feel ashamed
that you feel that way or you feel like
I shouldn't feel this way how long you
been sober at this point at this point
it's eight years eight years something
like that so do you feel like you should
have transcended that at this point yeah
I mean I feel like you know I feel like
we're both sort of success stories you
know and I want to close the door on
that and that's a pipe dream you know
yeah that doors will always be you know
if it's not wide open it'll be a jar or
it'll be a crack or it'll be latched
poorly you know and like ready to spring
back open and I know that I just need to
you know to live with that but it is
frustrating to to feel like you're
you've gone so far down the road with
sobriety and then to have a craving like
that I do this is the thing I don't I've
had a million opportunities to drink you
know I mean Jesus on this last tour when
I was you're basically living in dive
bars I know I said in like a high
vibrating environment can it - like
optimal sobriety but the point that I'm
driving at really that I want to that I
want to get to is this is kind of an
endemic thing with alcoholics like even
people who have been sober for a long
time suddenly they have an urge and they
feel bad about themselves like I can't
believe that I have that urge or that
compulsion like haven't I move past this
but you have to remember that if you're
an alcoholic like you're a true real
alcoholic yeah that is your default
state of mind in your condition so you
should just understand that that goes
with the territory and it's a little
kind of like red flag like oh maybe I
need to take a little contrary action to
get back on track but of course you're
gonna feel that way from time to time
yeah you know the miracle is that you
don't act on that it's like you're gonna
have those emotions you're gonna feel
that way periodically it's what you do
in response to that that dictates you
know life outcomes and you know the
miracle is that is not that the
alcoholic you know the sober alcoholic
stays sober the mirror is the miracle
all jumbled my thoughts but essentially
the miracle is that you're not drinking
every day like you forget that right
that's your default state and you've put
together eight years without doing that
so you have a craving from time to time
congratulations you're an alcoholic
shouldn't be ashamed of that it's just a
little nudge to say hey maybe I should
take a look at whatever is going on with
me physically and emotionally that led
to that craving so I can you know maybe
shift my behavior or my environment a
little bit to nip that in the bud so
that doesn't come up next time it gets
even more interesting on this last tour
in England I was I was traveling with
this band bird cloud who are alcohol
aficionados they they appreciate the
sauce and and and they're brilliant
musicians and brilliant writers and it
was you know as our privilege to tour
with them and also day after day I was
like uh and then you know towards the
end of the tour we were in London and I
had sort of like you know after you're
on the road for a while you get used to
setting things up a certain way I put my
capo here I put my slide here I put my
you know my thing water or seltzer here
and and then I got up on stage and great
night like sold out room in you know and
to be in a foreign country and have
people singing your songs back to you I
mean dad that's like such a [ __ ]
great thing yeah and I went up and I
like did my first song reach down grab
my drink took a swig of it and it was
pure vodka and likes not the first time
this has happened to you know right
about that time and that was a mixed
vodka drink this was straight vodka
which got me thinking I was like did did
somebody do this to me on purpose or
what like what but I like felt it in my
mouth and I spit it out back into the
glass and I did the rest of the set
totally cottonmouth like not drinking
anything you know and that's weird to
have something like that happen in the
public eye and and then you have to go
through the rest of the show and the
whole time I was thinking like well I
already got a little bit why not just
you know right now I also have that
millisecond thing where
in your mouth and it's almost like like
what is your knee-jerk unconscious
reaction like swallow or spit like if
you go that can go either way
yeah yeah and and so though and every
alcoholic justification was going
through my head of like oh I already got
a drop down my throat it's already like
it you know it's already tainted or
whatever and but I never did I know I
didn't take a drink I you know as soon
as I got off stage I pounded a couple
bottles of water and that made me
realize that the cravings that I've had
where I like really want to drink that's
not what's going on I really don't want
to drink because I had I had everything
teed up for the perfect excuse where I
had accidentally taken a drink and then
it would have been so easy I'm on tour
like in a foreign country I've ever I
had every excuse lined up to justify a
good relapse and I didn't do it and I
realized it's because I really don't
want to drink and when I get those
cravings about I really want to drink I
really you know it's I miss being young
I miss being 22 I'm having a hard time
dealing with ageing it's like a 40 year
old man it's [ __ ] is really bumming
it's a romantic it's a romantic
attachment or relationship with a bygone
era in which you were carousing around
Brooklyn and New York like doing
whatever yeah yeah it's it's it feels
like a time machine in a bottle where I
can just have a drink and go back there
to being a kid to hanging all my friends
that you know falling down on the river
or you know whatever [ __ ] we used to
do and I you know I I posted something
where I said you know I've lost more
friends to Parenthood then you know
alcoholism drug addiction and suicide
combined you know please Artie if this
scourge has affected you
like I'd be in a smart ass of course but
it's funny it's true man like I you know
I friend I feel like I'm one of the one
of the last if not the last of my
friends to to not be married to not have
children and it is to a point where like
I just I
I had alienated all my friends and now I
sort of gotten them back but then I've
lost them again to Parenthood yeah and
is it is it Parenthood or is it just
growing up where the lifestyle choices
the free time entertainment choices have
pivoted away from some of your cherished
most favorite occupations the wolf I
mean a lot of it is Parenthood a lot of
my friends have you know young you know
two kids under four or something like
that
and also people I the juxtaposition of
the words dinner and party always
bothered me because I was like man it's
one or the other like what's a liquid
dinner that's different like I I mean I
remember government we threw some party
when I was like 20 living in Colorado
and like my roommates girlfriend made
all this like awesome food and everybody
was just coked to the gills and hammered
and by the end of the night almost
nothing had been eaten there was just
like cigarettes put out and the like you
know penny pasta would right and yeah
but you look back on that and that's the
good old that's yeah you miss yeah why I
remember all the like the funny [ __ ]
about it and you know in the times when
we were just like laughing
uncontrollably and I missed that you
know I I'm glossing over the next
morning right yeah you're not you're not
playing it through to its conclusion
yeah right so what's helpful to me when
I start to romanticize the drinking days
is to really like you remember those
episodes but then just okay what
happened after that and what happened oh
yeah what happened you know it yes and
then follow the thread and then you're
like oh yeah that's why I don't drink
yeah and and listen I mean I I most of
the time I love not drinking I love not
apologizing for the first half of the
next morning to people is so great like
to get into an argument with somebody to
be able to say well actually I remember
that I said this and to be able to
remember it and not just have to yeah I
mean that's that's great and like
I'm running again I'm training for a 50k
in December like it's going well I had
like a real strong 20-mile run the other
day where I was just like flying and I
let you know I'd like to like at the end
of the night when we're loading out
being like no I got this I can drive
home or I can take care of this
situation you know to be to make a
positive contribution to be in control
and stuff but I for me my youth is so
stitched through with with alcohol and
coughs are up and all the other stupid
[ __ ] that we used to do you know that I
think in my brain that's the that's
become a shorthand you know or a signal
for youth you know the I you know I I
had actively planned to be dead a long
time ago and I so I I don't know how to
how to live now or how to have fun or I
mean I'm starting I'm starting to figure
it out I'm starting to get an idea but I
mean a lot of I don't know I feel like a
lot of people like after like 38 or 40
they're like alright well now now I'm we
now we gained 40 pounds and we quit the
band and we sell the gear and we don't
do this anymore we don't do that anymore
and we just sort of like they just sort
of like I mean that you know that you
know the over the hill right that they
just like alright now we're just gonna
coast in - have you seen that TV show on
HBO called togetherness are marked
applause created it's it's like it goes
right to the heart of what you just said
yeah it's basically like a cast of
characters who are all right at that age
where they're making that transition
from what their life used to be like
single to trying to become responsible
adults and parents and what gets baked
into that I think you would I think you
would relate to it oh I got to check it
out hey you should check it out it's
cool but here's the thing man I mean I
you know I couldn't do what you're doing
I mean you spend an inordinate amount of
time like you know dive bars touring you
know on the road and and hanging out
with you know people that that are
drinking a lot and doing that you know
living that kind of lifestyle yeah I I
now would wear me down it does wear me
down I mean it does tire me out but I
realized that from the experience I had
of like getting sober and then three
weeks later going to work in a bar and
having to work in a bar and stay sober
that you know I think um alcoholics in
early sobriety they have to build the
the castle or the fortress or the the
barricades in their outside life that
you don't step into a bar you don't hang
out with those people anymore you don't
you know and and I and I think that's
absolutely the right thing to do but I
couldn't do that so I I had to build
that barricade in my head and and I
think the risk of failure is really high
when you're when you're doing that and I
mean there's a reason that my story is
interesting is because most people who
try and do what I did
don't it doesn't work but now at this
point I have that [ __ ] in my head you
know and and then when I tasted that
vodka in my mouth I mean it it tasted
awesome you know I was like vodka I love
you where have you been you know and
also I was like you don't do that
anymore and it was just a gut reaction
of like no spin it out that's not you
know and like my body can finally reckon
that is poison dude you you went to
great pains to get that in the past but
it is poison it is actually you know
there's an adage in sobriety that you
know if you're truly sober you can go
anywhere like you shouldn't you
shouldn't you you shouldn't have to
avoid you know this place or that place
because it might trigger you in a
certain way but that there has to be
kind of a purpose for wandering into a
location that you might imperil the you
know the solidity of your of your sober
program and what always mystifies me is
that you do this alone like I can't do
it alone I need other people I knew you
know I need the secret society and
everything that comes with that to stay
sober and I know what it's like to step
outside that and I've done so at my
peril and it hasn't worked out so you
know I stay close but like you're you
still are holding on to this sort of
self will run
self-styled approach to sobriety and I
have no judgment on that it's your
eighth year sober man like that's
amazing but it's it's curious to me how
you're able to do that especially when
your lifestyle you know finds you in all
kinds of locations that aren't conducive
to the highest vibration rich know that
you're with me everywhere yeah I if
you're not there you're still there
you know you and a couple other friends
are like definitely people who I carry
on my shoulder in my head you know with
me wherever I go you know so that
because I have moments of weakness and I
have moment I definitely have moments of
nihilism you know words like my nihilism
is in it's in regression but it could
easily come back you know and I just
think that you know that's not the life
that you would want for me you would be
worried you would be concerned that you
know I mean there's a lot of things that
it would you know I mean I listen I know
at this point that there I can't I
couldn't alienate you as a friend if I
tried but I know too that if I started
drinking that it would be really hard
for us to be friends you know and so I
you know and I've other I have other
friends like that you know but um so I
don't go into these places alone I bring
I bring you and a couple other people
with me but one I think one of the
things that that made me sort of bail
out of running and the ultra community
and stuff like that is I felt like you
know one of the things I love about
about Dave Clark and I love about you is
that that the journey you travel on your
feet is less important than the journey
you travel the distance you cover in
your head you know and that it was about
you know going out there and like you
know um having an experience it's like a
Vision Quest or something like that you
know the end and then you know sort of
doing these races and interacting with
people you know for them it just seemed
sort of like
um boot camp or cardio exercise or you
know and I would get into conversations
I mean in Ultra community yeah I think
there's a lot of seekers there you know
for sure yes and absolutely and and also
you know what I was seeing may not be
what was accurate I may have been
looking for debt dissatisfaction and
then I found right yeah you have to you
have to filter that through your own
yeah prism of perception whatever the
opposite of rose-colored glasses or
whatever goggles mission is wearing
welders shades terrible everybody's out
to get me the that's that's true that's
right you finally see my see how I feel
no the you know sorry they're you know
and a lot of times I would find myself
in these sort of like hitchhiker
conversations you know like that when
you're hitchhiking if if somebody says
oh man I'm glad we finally got Trump in
the in office he's doing a great job you
would be like yep uh-huh and look at the
beautiful day that we're having you know
in because it when you're hitchhiking
you're at somebody else's they're
helping you out you're not going to get
into a protracted conversation with them
about religion or politics or gun
control or whatever the hot-button
issues are you're just going to toe the
line you're just going to surf along you
know and then I would find myself
getting into these conversations with
people on the trails or whatever where
you know oh I prefer this kind of gel or
whatever no sigh man this is [ __ ]
boring me to death and and I felt that
and I and in hindsight I'd know that
this is wrong but this is one of the
things that led me to with the current
Empire Strikes Back phase that I'm going
through which is that I felt that it was
time for me to move into like a life of
the mind and that I really wanted to be
writing more to be creating more to have
new experiences to to reinvent myself as
an artist and as a musician and make
[ __ ] and produce stuff and I you know I
felt like you know I was I was boxing
and I was kickboxing and I was going to
the gym
and stuff like that and that just seemed
like it seems like a waste of time and
in hindsight it absolutely wasn't but
sometimes you have to leave the trail in
order to be able to look back and be
like oh that's where the trail was right
there that's where I left it right I
mean it well I've always seen you as
somebody who you know and this is clear
in your writing like you took up
ultrarunning
not because you were just gonna become a
career ultra runner this is this was an
attempt to get out of your comfort zone
and really you know shake things up in
your life - you know reframe your
perspective and and and you know
recreate new habits that could set you
on a new trajectory and I think it did
that right yeah so there's something to
be said for it's not that like oh you
walked away from it so it's a defeatist
thing like okay what's the next thing
that's out of my comfort zone that's
gonna challenge me in a new way once it
stops sort of pressing you you know
pressing the outer boundaries of your
envelope it's time to look in other
areas perhaps I mean there's always you
know I talked about this with David
Clarke and I'm sure you have as well
like he kept pushing and pushing and
putting it's like dude you know at what
point does it tip over into its own form
of addiction and compulsion and
obsession because there's always going
to be a crazier thing that you can do
and like what are you actually trying to
learn about yourself yeah and then does
it become you know the enemy of the
thing that you aspire for yourself yeah
the and that's you know the craving new
things craving new sensations that's
learning that's curiosity that's to be
encouraged you know and expanding your
realm of knowledge and putting yourself
you know outside of your comfort zone
that's great but also craving new things
and new experiences is how I got into
trouble with drugs and alcohol and and
also you can't spend your whole life
questing for the new looking for the new
thrill you know sometimes you you have
to reach a point where you say enough is
enough this is you know I I got there
but there's a distinction between
chasing the thrill or trying to get high
or trying to escape your reality versus
yourself in a position to fail and grow
as a learning experience for yourself
and sometimes I think those lines get
blurred because they can it's all in
your relationship to them that will
define whether it's one or the other
yeah and so it it requires a certain
level of awareness to make sure that
your that your motivations are true and
that you're not using it to escape or to
numb or to you know basically truncate
your growth as opposed to amplify it
yeah I I think that you and I both have
the tendency to divide things into these
are the things that I can do and these
are the things that I can't do and then
every time you move something from one
category of the thing I can't do into
the category that I can do then suddenly
it loses meaning Atlas's yeah I can do
that it doesn't it doesn't mean anything
you know wait what about the things that
I can't I think that's a little bit
through your prism you know like I had I
had this woman Gretchen Rubin on the
podcast who wrote a book all the four
tendencies and she basically through
extensive study her her her thesis is
that all human beings can be divided
into one of four categories in terms of
how they respond to external and
internal expectations and one of the
categories is rebel which is basically
the person who doesn't like to be told
you know when they have to show up or
they want to be they want to make that
decision for themselves and I could say
without you having to take the quiz that
would determine the other three
categories clearly a rebel right so the
minute it starts becoming
institutionalized let's say ultrarunning
or whatever like oh this it becomes sort
of an identified entity defining thing I
can see you as being somebody who's
going to push up against that and then
move in the other direction yeah because
you don't want to be boxed into a corner
in that way yeah and and and I will
jeopardize my own wellness just to not
be in a box or I'll do damage to myself
right just as unique because you have
this incredible urge to say [ __ ] you
yeah yeah I do that is like my eye it's
like I have it on the back of my eyelids
man and it's so hard you know I mean
it's um it's not always bad you know I
mean with with my sister and with with
her two daughters that's one of the
things that I work with on them is to
know when to say [ __ ] you and like stand
up for yourself and say no I this is
where I draw the line I'm not gonna
stand for this I'm not gonna put up with
this you know this is not this is not
okay but [ __ ] you can't be your mantra
it can't be your default you can't just
do that all the time you know and I need
jerk to it so quickly all the time and
I'm trying to overcome it and it's hard
you know but um but yeah I mean the you
know I said I was thinking about this
you know as soon as something becomes a
hashtag it's over yeah you know and like
what it is what do you do when
everything's hash tag well that's what
that is where we are right now I what
that's when you need to revisit your you
know you know I also say like you know
anything you know short enough to put in
a tweet is oversimplification you know
and that's short enough to put in a
tweet you know so like it's you know but
if you look but but I'm wrong you know
and I guess that's that's my point is
I'm wrong when I say that that you know
the me to hash tag that was I was
incredibly meaningful that was like such
a weird couple of days on social media
where every woman that I knew was
telling stories of how they'd been
sexually harassed abused assaulted and I
knew that it was pervasive and I knew
that it was everywhere and I did not
know that it was like nearly universal
and and and more than that you know the
that that was the kind of in the the
repetitive Rhines have been assaulted as
well but the the real eye-opening thing
for me with with that me to hash tag was
how it was almost every woman ever
everywhere right
and everybody has a stop all the time
like
constant barrage of harassment and and
you know in serial abuse and stuff like
that so any nullity of social media to
kind of galvanize and organize that you
know that thought experiment was
unbelievably powerful ripple effects of
that you know culturally are massive
like I read just today that the Conde
Nast family of magazines is no longer
gonna work with Terry Richardson that is
so so long because that's another like
open secret yeah yeah I mean I get I
can't believe that that that guy hasn't
been like run out of the country you
know I mean he's like people in New York
knew about that ten years ago but people
in Hollywood knew about Harvey Weinstein
twenty years ago you know and that's and
that's the thing is that it seems like
um despicable male behavior is like this
Universal open secret that's just sort
of like and that was an interesting
thing because when it's merged with
power then it creates fear and it
becomes institutionalized and it's
amazing how how it can be perpetuated
for so long but I feel like you know we
live in a transparent age and that stuff
doesn't fly anymore
and things get routed out with the you
know extreme rapidity it was it was so
interesting to for me to measure my own
response to you know to reading all
these stories and then to engage with my
female friends who are sort of like yeah
we told you you know not none of that
none of them were surprised by the you
know millions and millions of stories
and you know the the prominent women you
know the politicians actors you know who
had been who had endured that and nearly
all of my male friends were like holy
[ __ ] you know and it was just I mean I
felt it was a watershed moment yeah
Julie has crazy stories I mean she
jumped in and and shared a little bit
but you know she's told me over the
years some bananas stories of guys that
she worked with in and worked for
working underneath in the garment
industry and it's appalling
yeah but you said earlier you dropped
this little bomb you said you're in your
Empire Strikes Back phase like what does
that mean so I got earlier this year I
turned 40 mmm
which is colossal bummer as you know
life ends at 40 come on man that's when
my life start I know I know
and and I was I had been feeling not
just depressed I mean I usually feel a
little depressed but like just [ __ ]
run down you know and like I felt like I
was gonna sort of float away from the
earth at any moment and and I was like
okay I gotta go to the doctor and just
like it's time and you just physically
run down yeah yeah and the so the doctor
did all the blood work and stuff and the
you know he went down my sort of test
results and he was like you know your
blood sugar is high I mean you're
pre-diabetic and this is a month after
my godfather my uncle died of diabetes
you know complications from diabetes and
most of my family is diabetic and and I
knew that it was sort of waiting in the
wings for me but I thought I had in like
another 10 years you know and and he was
like you have the testosterone of a 70
year old man and and he's like gruff
polish doctor in greenpoint and I was
like the doctor like you know my
girlfriend's really young and hot and he
was like you want me to cry for you only
you would like return to your doctor
after being delivered that news by
describing your girlfriend there I I
can't turn it off and so that's pretty
heavy 40 and you know you're not like I
mean you're a big guy you're carrying a
little extra weight around but like it's
not like you were like obese or anything
like that eat you're sober I'm sure this
was not and and and 6-time RRP guest
all the influence and all the meals that
you've had here and all the time that
we've spent together yeah it took that
for you to shake you up and in it well
it takes what it takes man it's like it
you know when the pain or the news is
dire enough then you wake up I I come
from the addict School of learning which
is don't learn anything until you're in
maximum pain and terror and then
meanwhile up until that point exploit
every yes opportunity yes for dinner Red
Bull for breakfast yeah just yeah do bad
[ __ ]
well I mean you had this for a while
there I haven't seen it lately but for a
while there you would pride yourself on
your Instagram posts of your dinner
which would be like a can of beans like
you and a can opener sitting on the
floor it's not like you know some
terrible marshmallow fluff or something
like that so all right well blood sugar
high pre-diabetic like how pre-diabetic
well that's the thing is it it's you
know it was just a one-time you know
test which you know it sort of measured
measures your fasting blood sugar at
that point but it doesn't give you a you
know relative to time but I did the test
twice and both times I tested high I
mean I think one time it was 110 and
then the other time it was whatever in
119 which is which is borderline which
is right on the border but I was already
having physical effects from it like
what my hands would get like blotchy and
itchy and I could I could sort of tell
when when I was having like a high blood
sugar episode and and I started getting
like pins and needles in my legs and
stuff and I was like really this quickly
but I did that 23andme genetic testing
and it told me the two things that I
already knew which is that fit
physically I'm basically bulletproof
except for super elevated risk for
diabetes and late-life dementia which is
those two issues are rampant
around my family mm-hmm and you know I
talked to my sister and I talked to a
couple of you know other people in like
red as sort of it and of course I was
leaving on tour the next day so it
wasn't it's just like we're gonna be
terrible news that you can't really do
anything about or learn anything about
two days before you leave to go on
another month-long European to her and
so I read as much as I could and did
what I thought was the right thing when
I was on tour and like you you know and
it made no difference you know what was
that what did you do exactly I you know
I mean I tried not to eat sugar you know
which was which I was I mean that is my
that is my poison of choice man
but you know over and above anything
else and you know and I tried to eat
less but I didn't really know what I was
doing and and then when I came back I I
was at Yale and I was like okay I'm just
going to avoid all sort of like refined
carbs and in sugar and that's gonna do
it and so I was keen to eating eggs for
breakfast and you know chicken salad for
lunch and you know pork chops and
whatever you know for dinner and and I
packed on more weight and my blood sugar
wouldn't go down and then I [ __ ] like
you know I I called I called Dave Clark
shout out to Dave Clark for taking my
call and when I was miserable and
terrified and I was like what do I do
you like you know and he was like he was
like I don't know you know I don't want
to preach I would never preach but since
you're asking plant-based is the way to
go that will that will fix you right up
and and he was right you know when I
went back to when I went back to Atlanta
I went like real hardcore of just so but
first of all after after Yale and you
trying to avoid all the sugars and the
refined carbs did you do your blood work
again and it was the same I know I
didn't I didn't really have like time or
not don't know I know I did I went on I
went on Amazon I bought one of those
little like pin
you know blood test things and I would
test it every morning after you know
fasting and and five times out of six it
would be high and sometimes really high
and I couldn't like figure out what it
was and then when I got back to Atlanta
and I was settled I just did like
plant-based with no fruits no no grains
sort of no refined anything just sort of
just greens and vegetables and that's
pretty dull for a couple of days and but
I did I think I did it for a week or two
or ten days or two weeks and then
finally I had a normal reading and then
I had another one and then it started
being balanced a string of normal
readings and that's amazing in two weeks
yeah you were able to rectify it yep and
then I did it for I don't know 40 days
60 days something like that before I
went back out on the road again lost 15
pounds without trying and stopped
testing my blood sugar in the morning
because what was the point
normal every time yeah I would also
suggest you listen to my podcast with
dr. Neal Barnard oh it was all about
that which which book did he write
prevent and reverse diabetes yes I have
that book you have that I have that book
I bought that book yeah I haven't I
haven't read at all yet but I have that
and I have how not to die right that's a
good one yeah and yeah dude you're never
gonna believe this but I've been doing
everything wrong why didn't you tell me
I can't I can't I don't I don't know
what to tell you man you had to figure
it out for yourself it's like telling a
telling a drunk they have to get sober
like they're not gonna hear it until
they're ready to get sober yeah up the
most amazing meals for you time and time
again but until you're ready to kind of
like look at it or your back is up
against the wall but I'm glad you made
that leap man yeah I would listen to
that podcast I would read both of those
books I'm not sure that you need to
remove
fruit from your diet I think you're
probably okay with that yeah I brought
fruit back in after once I'd sort of
gotten in normal and then it didn't
affect my right eye blood sugar at all I
mean I don't do dried fruit or something
you know yeah because it's easy to sit
down with a bag of dried cherries or
something like that no no you know fresh
yes we organic for yes but so you been
doing this well let me for as I am the
sort of everyman Lister let me say this
that it was hard it wasn't an easy
transition but it was absolutely worth
it you know so like I would say if if
somebody's on the cusp of trying it or
if they've tried it and failed try it
again and then try it again and then try
it again because it's totally worth it
and I really really struggled with it
but now I like I got my mind right you
know and I like I love having my oatmeal
with stevia in the morning and I'm like
I'm a killer lentil dishes and like you
know and I mean I know that I do the not
wings the like sliced cauliflower
prepared like wings and stuff and like
yeah I have a couple of good recipes
even like believe that you're telling me
this is like blowing my mind dudes like
hey you know but like you to a bunch of
cool recipes man I should do like a
right you know you're gonna have a
cooking show now on YouTube but like
let's walk through that because I think
in certain respects like we said at the
outset and you just reminded me like you
are standing for a lot of people that I
think struggle with this transition and
I think it is important to acknowledge
that yeah it's hard you have to step out
of your comfort zone you have to be
willing to like weather a little bit of
discomfort to get to the other side like
it's not like oh you snap your fingers
and everything's easy I know that's the
culture that we all want for ourselves
but if you've been eating a certain way
your entire life and then you're faced
with the prospect of throwing all that
out the window and doing something
entirely new it's going to be
uncomfortable it just is so rather than
trying to find a way to not make it
uncomfortable I mean sure you want
there's ways of you know sort of
cushioning
fall but but understand that that's okay
but if you can get through like two
weeks of trying to figure it out for
yourself like on the other end of that
is freedom
so stop fighting the idea that maybe
you're gonna be uncomfortable and just
accept that perhaps that's going to be
part of that journey yeah yeah there's I
mean you know there's there's nothing
worthwhile that you you know that you
get for free except maybe like sunshine
you know I mean like you have to work
for good things and it yeah I mean it
was definitely it's definitely
challenging I mean there were days where
I would feel sort of like bloated or
lightheaded or no energy or headachy and
stuff like that and I think that's
because your body's trying to acclimate
to a new way or because you weren't
doing it right or you were you were you
weren't eating enough calories like
looking back on it like doing a forensic
I think I think there's a you know a
bunch a bunch of different things I mean
one thing is just you know you're
radically trent you know in my case i
was radically transforming what I was
putting in my body right so what were
you eating before well you kind of
mentioned it a little bit garbage yeah
pork chops yeah yeah well I mean
particularly when you're on tour in
England not really an area known for its
cuisine or commitment to fresh
vegetables and stuff like that and then
also just road food you stop at the gas
station you like you know I mean you
sort of get and even if you're trying to
eat healthy if you get the like trail
mix pack you you're your body is your
body is an animal so you grab the trail
mix pack that has the MMS in it and it
has like tons of that super sugary dried
fruit that's you know like one step away
from candy so you know I mean I would
eat like whatever was that you know
Raisin Bran with the like super sugary
raisins the you know that was at the
continental breakfast at the hotel for
you know for breakfast coffee with you
know sugar and cream in it and then
lunch is whatever something at the gas
station a pack of gummy worms trail mix
if I'm feeling particularly what will
you hit and drive thrus to Ivana
McDonald's and
Arty's and stuff like that yeah I was
out on the road with my friend star Ana
who I love and she and I would just
bring the worst out of each other and
just not smoking cigarettes drinking Red
Bull and come on you're killing me so
stupid and I'm paying the price ma'am
I'm you know it it terrified me
and it you know it really depressed me
too to get that news from you know from
the doctor and one of the things I'll
say to you is that like there is all
there's all this sort of wave of stigma
around being being vegan you know I I
have a bit in in my sort of like comedy
stuff that I do where I say you know
vegan you know I treated like the n-word
I can only say when I'm when I'm quoting
a self-righteous close-minded [ __ ]
or singing along with Kanye do are you
kidding come on no but this is the thing
is that when somebody if you're trying
to make a change for the positive in
your life and somebody's like haha vegan
that's where you take a lesson from me
and say [ __ ] you
mmm that's where that's where that comes
in handy you know is it's my body it's
not yours shut up right you know this is
a decision that I've made this is an
amazing development in my life you
should ballet I have to say I'm super
proud of you I wasn't sure this day
would come
I'm glad that it's here and this is
fascinating but I think you know one
thing I think is interesting and I want
to hear your take on this is that as an
addict alcoholic in recovery whether
you're doing that in the context of a
structured program or more from a
freewheeling approach like yourself
there are certain rules that you erect
to orient your life around and and those
rules cannot be broken and if you're an
alcoholic it means you don't drink
that's just no matter what you don't
drink right you don't step over that
behind that's a non-negotiable thing and
that rule can be very easily applied to
diet you just say I don't eat you know
this I don't eat I don't eat animal
products
don't eat you know candy or whatever it
is like you can erect a couple very you
don't overcomplicate it it doesn't have
to be like you know there are doesn't
have to be 20 corollaries to every rule
but like if you just have like two or
three rules and like this is this is
like the marching you know this is the
marching rule for my life it removes a
lot of decision fatigue and because you
have experience with that in other areas
of your life I found that it's easy to
adhere to that because you have that
muscle has been flexed and is developed
so do you think about it in that context
you can just say like why me you can
even say like look I'm addicted to
drive-through or I'm into you know you
know I just can't have that in my life
that does not serve me I don't do that
anymore that's not who I am yeah I I
think human beings have a tendency to
take a lot of like subtle nuanced
decisions and make it into a binary
thing and that's oftentimes bad but in
this instance I think I think that's
absolutely the way to go is just you
know like I don't drink anymore I don't
I don't murder people I don't I mean you
know you know there are things that I
don't do you know and and drinking is
one of them and and yeah well also now
it's you know no animal products and
particularly for me no processed food
you know every once in a while like well
like oh I'm gonna get pasta and I can
feel it the next day men just like I
don't I don't feel right it's it's
awesome and it's delicious and I love it
you know and like I can how is a huge
bowl of pasta and I wake up the next day
feeling like I can I can tell from the
way my body feels that that was not what
I should have eaten last night and what
is your experience been with with
cravings like is that analogous to drugs
and alcohol have you noticed a shift
like how the cravings for those crazy
foods waned do you still live with those
and how do you confront and combat that
in the same way that now my body
recognizes that alcohol is a poison you
know if I you know putting you know
gummy worms in my mouth I'm like this
isn't food you know like you can sort of
recognize that and I can tell when
there it's like there's no way for me to
not be honest with myself anymore you
know now I just know that like this is
this is gonna make me feel like [ __ ]
tomorrow
or it's gonna make me Shelton feel like
[ __ ] in 15 minutes you know or I'm
eating the right thing I'm gonna feel
better dude I'm running better did you
know this if you eat a plant-based diet
you actually perform and recovery better
not know that [ __ ] I'm so it's such a
pleasure for me to be here today to drop
this knowledge on you Wow I'm gonna
really have to explore that in my book
about that I'm glad that you're finally
did you think that I was just biessing
or did you know I the whole time that I
was or not the whole time I was drinking
for most of the time that I was drinking
I knew that I was wrong I knew that I
was doing the wrong thing and I knew
that that and I think I understood that
I would have to quit one day or that it
you know that it would kill me and I
don't know how how honest I was with
myself about it because but when I quit
drinking I was like I quit drinking
oh you've quit drinking a million times
I said no no if you think about I've
taken a break a ton of times I've said
I'm not drinking for a week or I'm not
drinking for a month or even I'm not
drinking for a year but I've always put
an end date on it now I'm telling you I
quit drinking you know and the so yeah
that those the skills you develop as a
sober alcoholic have been you know have
been super helpful in you know in making
this transition and also the this is the
other thing to of like try everyday you
know like I screw up sometimes
particularly on the road it's hard and
like I still have a hard time being that
guy who's like I don't eat that you know
I exercise the health cop-out as often
as possible which is to say I can't eat
that
because I still I still approach you
know virtually everything in my life you
know from a financial capital
perspective you know that like ie um my
parents always said don't let food go to
waste and like this is what we have for
dinner you eat your dinner you know and
that kind of thing but but you know you
can use whatever you know in the same
way that we know with quitting drinking
you can say like oh I have to drive or
I'm working tonight
you know and that was really helpful for
me in the early days of you know like oh
I'm on the clock
I have to drive tonight or I'm feeling
sick you know I got to get over this
what you're saying I mean between the
lines here is it's less about you
adhering to the commitment you made to
yourself and versus navigating tricky
social situations and having to explain
yourself to others and the pressure that
comes with being an environment where
perhaps people are going to be less
understanding of the choice that you're
making yeah yeah I've seen the light and
like you know me man I wouldn't like if
it was something I was exploring or
something I was trying you know I
wouldn't come out and say it in this
form that like that I'm doing it but but
I'm doing it you know and I and I've
been doing it for a while you know and a
lot so how long has it been I mean it's
been what day is it today what month is
it over late it's uh you know three or
four months Wow you know I've screwed up
a couple of times everybody does the oh
it's hard like on the road and stuff
like that
my struggle on the road you know on the
road sometimes it ends up being closer
to vegetarian than vegan but I whenever
possible I try to and it's also it's one
of those things where I said you know
I've told myself you can't be your what
you're doing is admirable you can't beat
yourself up for a falling short on it
someday because there was nothing else
to eat or you were just starving or
whatever you know but um but if I screw
up it's like you know I'll eat a piece
of cheese pizza with vegetables on it
it's not like oh well I screwed up so
I'm going to go
sizzler for yeah yeah that's we should
talk about the testosterone things but
before we get to that I do want to talk
about that yeah I'm interested in in
exploring the relationship between like
food and emotions in the sense that when
you get sober you become more aware of
the extent to which you medicate your
emotional state through using or
checking out in various ways so if you
had any you know discoveries or
epiphanies about about how you used food
in the same way or no yeah yeah why I
mean I you're never gonna believe this
but I found note that I'm a really like
reward-based why are you laughing I you
know that I'm a I you know I'm like the
rat that's been in the cage for too long
that like I'm not gonna do anything
unless I know that there's a treat at
the end you know there's got to be some
reward oh I will never press the lever
just just for kicks you know there's got
to be like if I do this then I can have
that if I do this then I can have that
that kind of thing and you know and then
I'm starting to realize that like and
and I've and this is you know one of the
ways in which I sort of like ruined
running for myself and ruin a lot of
things for myself which is that like
it's a great privilege that I have that
I'm able to write I should that should
be its own reward I should just write
and then RiRi you know read what I wrote
and say that's good there's an
interesting part there that's a good
line that's a good sentence I wasn't yet
oh that's a funny part that should be
enough for reward should go out for a
run and be like oh yeah it was nice I
saw some squirrels there was that weird
snake whatever you know like and that
should be the reward there doesn't need
to be a chocolate bar waiting for me at
the end right I'll do this run and then
I'll reward myself with a double
cheeseburger or what which completely
undoes the yeah any good that the run
does for you but it has it has helped
you running
oh absolutely dude yeah one of the
things that are you getting your protein
dude how is this happening
the there's
a weird parallel universe right now I
understand what's happening Freaky
Friday I'm glad I didn't tweet I'm glad
we didn't go you were like what are we
gonna talk about today I was like I got
a couple of good things yeah I got one
or two things you know the but yet the
the protein thing has never I mean it's
early days for me but it's never come up
for me as an issue of like you don't
have some deep-rooted like innate sense
that you're lacking protein in your body
no and I and I didn't do any protein
powders or you know cuz I was a signal
that's processed food you know and I and
dude I I mean I didn't do the
plant-based thing out of like you know
let me try this or this would be a good
idea I was [ __ ] terrified I was just
like I was like I'm gonna die and I just
see my uncle died in a horrible way
we're house is he 62 you know and he's
my adopted sisters father so she lost
her father he and it was one of those
thing it was just this horrible
experience of him like dying six times
and coming back to life five and the
last time there was nothing left you
know and then they had to make a
decision to pull the plug you know and
this is a you know this is a young man
with with children you know I knew him
my entire life he was always there with
us from you know when we were kids and
he was you know on some of the uncle's
were cool and some of the aunts were
cool and other other ones weren't and
Edie was always like I'm god I still
have a letter that that he wrote me when
I was in graduate school that I haven't
been able to locate and it's such a
mercy that I haven't been able to locate
X and know when I find it it would just
make me it made me break down but it was
so hard to lose head and and and I knew
without knowing much about diet and
nutrition I was like dude you're 60
pounds overweight if you're having
health issues that's it you know or even
if that's not it losing that weight
isn't won't hurt and it will probably
help you know I feel like this is [ __ ]
that's preventable and and so many
people my family are
you know diabetic or pre-diabetic and
overweight and you know and that's and
let's you know let's be honest about
this too you know I mean so many people
were like you know you know you you're
you know you're a young guy how could
this happen to you you're so skinny I'm
not skinny I'm everybody in America is
overweight I'm less overweight than a
lot of the people that we yeah and
you're a big dude and you can kind of
yes you know wear a baggy t-shirt and no
one's gonna say you're overweight exact
like you've had a huge gut or anything
like that and and also it's like you're
running all the time and you're running
ultras how dare you accuse me of this
but you're makin run ultras and be
overweight and you definitely how much
have you lost cuz you're you're the trim
s that I've seen you I'm probably down
like 15 pounds mmm
I want to get down another seven or
eight and we'll see if that happens or
not you know but but I'm I'm back
running there's a lot of I mean I have
been you know since getting scared I
have been farm and you know props to my
girlfriend Mattie to I mean she's really
been like you you got to take care of
yourself you need to that you can't do
the things that you do without taking
care of yourself so you know there's
also sorry I don't mean interrupt you
but I gotta say that jump in and we've
talked about this before but there is
something deeply bread inside of you
that prides yourself on you know you're
kind of rogue approached lifestyle like
you're your you have an attachment like
in a romance and in the same way you
romanticize your your past drinking life
you kind of romanticize the beat up then
and the the crappy hotel rooms and the
kind of lifestyle of the traveling
Roadshow you know that you live yeah and
and this is sort of requiring you to
re-examine that and perhaps let go of
that or at least not romanticize it yeah
I mean I'm not saying change your I'm
not saying you're not gonna go do the
things that you love doing I'm saying
you're you're the pride that gets
attached to like I live this way you
know like sort of in defying
it's that rare thing like I'm defying
cultural norms and I'm gonna live this
way and [ __ ] you
yeah I I mean I'm part of it you know it
there's it's a balancing act because
part of it is change and evolve and
incorporate the the lessons that you
learn in your life and respond to the
wisdom that you're confronted with and
also be true to yourself you know and I
think you can do both of those things
and I'm trying hard to do both of those
things but the yeah I mean I'm still
playing out dramas from when I was a
little kid of like you know young man
you need to learn how things are done
and I'm like no I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna do it my way and like that has
served me and it has hurt me you know
incredibly and so I mean let's put it
this way though you know I you know I've
been on the road a lot you know I'm in
bars a lot I've yes I'm still the guy
with you know both middle fingers in the
air but now I'm saying [ __ ] you you
don't need to be drunk all the time to
be a rebel and if you want to if you
want to smash the state why don't you
make sure that you have the tools to do
it why don't you take care of the most
important tools you have which is
yourself if you want to change things
you know the the I said this to a friend
the other day and got [ __ ] for it but
I'll say it again you know the the most
the most ret the most dangerous thing
that we could do in America is have
healthy black people because but you
know poverty malnutrition and this
system of you know government subsidies
for meat and McDonald's and stuff like
that that being the only food that's
available in low-income neighborhoods
you know the do your best to stick
around be healthy for a long time and be
a pain in the ass for your enemies you
know I really believe that
well let's flush this out a little bit
because like that's that's kind of a
loaded statement to say
want to make sure I understand you yeah
the so I mean I come from sort of a
culture of of resistance of pushing back
against you know corporate America
mainstream America mainstream ideals and
the but then within that the sort of
punk rock community there's you know
there's this there's the there's the
idealist wing of like we need to change
things women need to have an equal say
women need to have representation women
need to have equal power black people
need to be allowed to own the places
where they live and not white landlords
and black tenants you know that there is
this stratification in America of and
it's and time and time again it's people
of color who come out on the losing end
well every time that the law is involved
you know and so that so in the sort of
punk-rock community there's still like
super idealist wing of like you know
like let's change things let's move
forward let's be progressive and then
there's this sort of the other side that
like the nihilist side of law an artist
well not even anarchist of but like
nihilist just like not even like let's
go out and smash it but let's just get
[ __ ] up you know and like real punk
rock is like waking up and having an you
know a shot and a beer for breakfast and
then like you know doing lines all day
or whatever and and a lot of people try
to try to imagine that those are
compatible things but when you're when
there is a culture of self-destruction
of of like oh we're just gonna eat
garbage and we're going to you know
we're not gonna do what you tell us to
we're not going to take care of our
bodies you don't have to have there
doesn't need to be a villain because
you're you're undermining yourself at
every turn you know and if if people you
know there's a lot of
a lot of musicians and comics with with
political aspirations and you know who
are good at you know tweeting about [ __ ]
but but then in their own personal lives
are alcoholics or addicts are massively
overweight our Ralphie may our friend
Ralphie may just died at 45 yeah and
it's you know that's the simple thing is
that if you really want to if you want
to [ __ ] [ __ ] up if you want to upend the
existing balance of power be healthy
right so essentially like the the sort
of the punk rock of being hell we had we
live in a culture in which systems are
erected that are inherently repressive
to a lower socioeconomic class because
healthy food is not accessible or
affordable yeah it's like it's yeah so
it perpetuates and further entrenches
the divide between the haves and the
have-nots which of course is
overwhelming or essing people of color
yeah and all of that so the proc saying
is to is to find a way to somehow you
know transcend those erected cultural
barriers that stand in between that
person and being healthy so that you you
can be physically healthy enough to
stand up to the man and exactly that's
what you're saying
exactly I get that exactly and I mean
listen I I mocked the like vegan Punk's
my whole life and I was wrong you know I
was wrong do you want to apologize to
Jay Jay right now I probably on the
phone call good John I'm sorry you're
right I was wrong I don't know that's
like that's that's a start
you know so what about this testosterone
thing oh that well I mean man you think
there's a lot of like weird feelings
tied up you know and attachments to the
word vegan the testosterone
such a I mean I I just instantly felt
like ashamed you know and went and then
when I sort of got over that and I was
like no if I feel ashamed about this I
should just talk about it with people
because and then it was you know sort of
the like like the diabetes thing of you
know people were like oh what I never
thought you would have a testosterone
problem you know about because I'm tall
or because I have a deep voice or
because I have hairy arms or you know
what I mean like or because I make
raunchy jokes or something like that you
know I don't know what the it's weird
how that gets tied into identity when
it's really just a you know it's is yeah
the biological physiological hormonal
thing yeah and you know one of the
things I learned is that you know libido
is not just testosterone and
testosterone is not just libido you know
and when I was talking to my doctor when
you know when when he said like yeah
your testosterone is terribly low I was
like really you know like you know I
still like I can have sex and stuff and
he was like well are you depressed and I
was like yes I would like to die right
now and every minute of every day for
the last 18 months I would love to die
and he was like well yeah that's that is
the first the biggest the most lasting
manifestation of low testosterone is
depression so he put you on testosterone
therapy or what is the protocol for
tried to yeah and I said let me see if I
can remedy it on my own so I haven't
gone back in to get that retested I'm
going back to New York in December and
I'm gonna get that tested I feel like
it's rallying because I don't feel like
dying every second of every day anymore
and so I read a ton on testosterone its
function and how it's so if you
testosterone is effective or it helps
building lean muscle mass
if you have lean muscle mass you have
higher testosterone so the the first
thing that I did to to try and remedy my
situation was I did like the five
thousand squats in a month you know
social media challenge and trying to
rope a ton of my friends and to do five
thousand squats with me because if
you're gonna do one simple exercise you
can sort of do anywhere squats are the
best exercise and it's working the you
know the biggest muscles in your body
and that's what you need to work to to
build us you know to build testosterone
and I feel like that has is that true if
you do if you do like intense weight
training that has a that will actually
boost your body's natural ability to
produce testosterone well yes
what I mean everybody feel free to
fact-check me and debunk this so we get
good information but I've read stuff
that point two points to old-school like
Charles Atlas strongman stuff that like
deadlifts and squats and stuff like that
real gym rat [ __ ] that stuff and then
high-intensity you know interval
workouts helping to raise your
testosterone so I've been doing the you
know Tabata the Tabata Tabata stuff I've
been doing the squats and stuff I
haven't gotten a gym membership because
I hate the gym but I am going to get a
gym membership and do that stuff and but
I also and this is my own extrapolation
but something tells me that when you
know what when I stop eating cheese
fries and Cheetos and gummy bears and
start eating cauliflower and asparagus
and flaxseed and that that's not gonna
hurt my testosterone that is gonna help
my test loss for I think it's gonna hurt
your
so you haven't you haven't been back to
that and polish doctor in Greenpoint
since since he delivered the bad news
yeah no I well I mean that's that's the
thing is that I like I don't really live
in New York yeah more but that's where
my health insurance is so I have limited
access to it so I mean in that shitty
gray area of like WebMD and you know in
Google and like I kind of feel by
I definitely feel better I feel better
mentally I feel better physically I feel
like it's on the upswing I'll check back
in in December when I get my results you
know I've been taking fight it I was
vitamin D deficient so I've been taking
vitamin D been taking zinc Brazil nuts
are supposed to be helpful - yeah that's
helpful with the selenium in them it's
they have a high degree of selenium that
supposedly has an impact on boosting
testosterone but I another really
interesting thing was how how insecure
men are talking about testosterone and
testosterone billions yeah how do you
bring it up and well no I did something
about it because I was like this
embarrasses me so I'm gonna post it
because every time I've done something
like that before
the response has been overwhelming and I
had a bunch of a bunch of guys write to
me saying oh yeah my testosterone has
been really low and it's been low for a
long time and you know and either
they're just living with it or they're
saying you know let let us know how it
works and you know we'll try the same
regimen and the or yeah I've been on
hormone replacement therapy for four
years
you know and you know I talked to my dad
my you know my dad you know had a
similar thing in his 40s you know his he
had really low testosterone and and you
know and he's been on hormone
replacement therapy and I you know I I
guess a lot of guys are I just I'm 40
you know um that seems to be too young
to sign up for because once you start
taking it your honor for the rest of
your life yeah I mean I don't know
enough about it to speak intelligently
but it's frightening to consider you
know once you like you said like once
you begin that like what is the
long-term impact on your body's own
native ability to produce that are you
clamping down on that are you depressing
it and and if you go off it can your
body rebound and and take over or are
there long term implications to that
like I don't know yes it's enough to
basically when give me pause before yeah
when you start replacing your body's
like testosterone your body stops making
its testosterone so basically if you do
hormone what I understand is once you
start down that road then that's it then
you're on it you know for the rest of
your life and I I keep tiptoeing about
around this and I hate it so I'll just
come out with it I'm also taking
fermented fish oil that was one of the
things that Tim Ferriss said I was like
I'm not gonna try and hack the diabetes
thing I'm just gonna do the right thing
and do plant-based and the notable
exception is fermented fish oil because
why Tim Ferriss had a his regimen for
boosting your testosterone was Brazil
nuts zinc vitamin D and fermented fish
oil and that's what I found in a panic I
was like I'm gonna do this and see if it
works you might want to well first of
all you gotta you got to be really
careful about mercury levels in fish oil
even the purest forms have been found to
be tainted so you got to make sure that
the brand that you're getting is like
top-notch and I would suggest that you
might also want to look at dr. Michael
Greger nutritionfacts.org website has
some videos about fish oil and the
differences between fish oil and algal
algae algae algae based okay you might
find that interesting okay yeah I know
that there's more reefs
that I have to do you know and like my
methods of combating this are far from
ideal you know cuz it sort of was sprung
on me
and then I just you know look at that
look at the look at the changes that you
made in the last three or four months I
mean that's pretty dramatic dude so
don't undercut or undermine like yeah
what you've done like I think it's I
think it's amazing I feel better
you know I like mentally I feel better
physically I feel dramatically better
you know I'd like to be able to run it
you know I've had nagging issues and um
with my my right foot my IT band my hip
my back you know and I've been like
trying to tackle all that stuff and it's
been a it's been such a hassle and it's
expensive and I hate like the guy who
goes the chiropractor three days a week
you know what it's [ __ ] working it's
working and it's totally worth it you
know just why why did it take me so long
to figure this [ __ ] out you're a
stubborn bastard you know like we all
are look I uh I've said all the time
like pain is the great mother people are
like you know what what caused you to
change I was dude I was in pain you know
pain is crazy how these choices are
available to all of us all the time and
yet it's so difficult to access them
until you know we're at that breaking
point it doesn't have to be that way
that's just the way that you know it
generally tends to work and with someone
as stubborn as you like you're gonna
have really been scared yeah yeah I you
know I mean losing my uncle really
helped you know it's that was
heartbreaking and that was also I was
like okay this is what lays that you
know behind door door a if I don't do
anything about this that's where I'm
headed you know and and also you know I
mean the it's true that whatever after
3540 like things start to slow down and
it's harder to do the stuff that we did
when we were younger so does that mean
you roll over and just you're like
oh yeah all right I'll gain 40 or 50
pounds and like let's Netflix and chill
you know for the right you know for
another 30 years before I die
or do you push back do you turn and
fight you know and do you say no this I
I'm not I'm not done being human yet and
having a full life and you know I still
got a ton of [ __ ] left to do you know
dude you're only 40 as someone who is 10
11 years further down the line no come
on well you know what and and I mean I
kept that in my head too you know that
you know you and JJ you know that you
guys are living huge lives right now you
know and and that's open to me that's
that that is an option you know and and
I gotta like just run towards that
instead of running [ __ ] Doug Stanhope
I love the guy so much the one of the
smartest people I've ever met in my life
[ __ ] aged like 30 years in the
last ten and it makes me so angry
how old is he now he's it's probably
your age but yes yeah I would imagine
differently arrived do you like that
yeah yeah for people that are listening
that that are maybe new to the show or
don't know Doug Stanhope super famous
amazing Indian who kind of inhabits this
counterculture sensibility and a sort of
Hunter s Thompson kind of way I suppose
this is a part yeah hard partying you
know fun-loving amazingly talented
comedian and friend of yours you've
opened for him he's not huge easy road
with this guy you've had crazy exploits
pre sobriety with him and you still you
still do gigs with him from time to time
he you drop in on his crazy Arizona
compound we do gigs from time to time
and and you know like you know the
friendship is still alive and like you
know I still whenever I finished songs
and stuff I sent him to him and I said I
you know see him whenever I can you know
I mean I've had you know some of the I
[ __ ] on everything you know that's the
way my brain goes but there have been a
like I've learned from Doug
at times like on you know to be on the
road playing a big theater oh there's
700 people there you know to just stay
open and just soak it up and be like
yeah these people are here to listen to
me play my songs my you know my songs as
I started right when I was whatever 20
or something like that and now and now
people know the words and it's so cool
or like you know I played a gig in his
like fun house which is his bar in his
backyard and Bisbee and I and like
that's a weird you know it's its own
universe down there yeah yeah has its
own time zone yeah it's really it's
another world you know but to be there
with you know in or in a room this size
with you know 40 people like you know
some of the the smartest most
groundbreaking entertainers I've ever
met some of my closest friends and to
have them all know the words to my songs
and to be there with them and to be a
peer you know and to see Doug you know
out in the crowds like singing along you
know like a real smile on his face not
sneer or a leer you know but just like
happy yeah that's powerful [ __ ] man that
is the good stuff yeah but also to not
overly you know get caught up in the I'm
sure there's a there's a there's a
charisma like a tractor beam like a
center of gravity around a guy like Doug
Stanhope that makes it very easy to kind
of just fall into that orbit and stay
there and start sure mimicking you know
his habits and yeah and and so to be
able to be part of that but also erect
your own boundaries around you know
things that you do and don't do has to
be tricky this that's one of the things
I wanted to talk about today too is is
the weird lives that we have like living
in public and expose you know exposing
our foibles in public and to have to to
be a public figure and toe a certain
line and and you know people's
expectations of us and I've really
struggled with that lately you know
between because because I'm friends with
you and I
meir you and I you know respect your
work and because I'm friends with Doug
and I admire Doug and I respect his work
and people you know come to shows either
having read the book or the long run or
something like that or heard me on the
podcast and expecting me to be in that
environment the person who I am here and
then people who have heard just my songs
on stanhope podcast or the stories I
tell on the stanhope podcast and they're
expecting that person and your fans and
Doug fans by and large are very smart
and very fluid people and they can I
think they're able to accept that I'm a
whole person better than I am I always
feel like I'm disappointing people
somehow like I'm letting people down you
know and because you feel like you have
to be you have to live up to a certain
persona that other people you imagine
you're projecting you are projecting
that they are projecting onto you
yes I'm projecting their projection yeah
and then I and then I that sounds like a
lot of work yeah man I it's [ __ ]
tiring thinking about myself constantly
well that is the great preoccupation of
every alcoholic yeah well I could I
could you know help you with a few sober
tools that enable you to tackle that a
little bit yeah but it's you know self
obsession is at the center of alcoholism
right and when you're caught up thinking
about yourself and how you're being
perceived and what do they think of me
then inevitably you're not the person
that a you want to be or that they want
you to be they want you to be present
and who you are yeah yeah people you
know I think people want you there in
the first layer they want you to be the
epithet that they understand you to be
so you know rich the runner or the
swimmer or rich the triathlete or rich
the vegan you know and for me they want
me to be you know michiga the drunk or
michiga the ultra runner or michiga the
writer or whatever but dry past that
layer is they just want you to be
authentic they want you to be a real
person they want you to be a real human
being you know and I think it's always
fascinating for us
to find out that like Neil Young is
really into model trains and I I love
that detail I love Neil Young he's such
a treasure
I've celebrate that Neil Young is still
alive and making records that he's made
a million records and he's such a weird
guy that he's just like really into
model trains Tyler Tyler saw him at the
grocery store the other day oh my god I
would have a hard time like holding
myself back from just like throwing
myself at his feet and just just tread
on me okay but the minute you're caught
up in how am i coming off to this person
is the minute that you stop being
authentic so I I wish I had remembered
the name of the person who said this but
I just read something on Twitter that
said you know like you you write a thing
or you make a song and then somebody
tells you you're an artist and that's
when the problem started I just somebody
tweeted that the other day and I saw
that we've got to figure out who it is
but it's you know who I think it was
yeah I think it was Neil Strauss yes
that's it that's who it was I'm seeing
later today actually really yeah oh my
god well tell him do you know are you a
fan of nails I I know nothing beyond
that tweet oh yeah he's nails amazing
but it's it's totally true man because
you know I I get caught up in my head
about [ __ ] you know about like Oh what
are people expecting me to do you know
or what what song are my fans gonna like
well [ __ ] [ __ ] the fans I need to write
a song that I like and if I like it
they'll like it
and if I think about them and try to
write to them I'll write a [ __ ] song
because I'm not being authentic there's
no question about that
you have to write from your heart and as
somebody who teaches writing at Yale
it's shocking to me that you have to
remind yourself of that you know that's
how it is though like we give advice for
all this [ __ ] and then as soon as we
give the good advice it like leaves our
brain immediately and then you're like
oh man I ya know I need to I'm hungry I
need something to actually practice the
thing that I tell other people to do all
day long yeah there's nothing worse than
having to take your own advice and on
that subject like how is the writing
going I want to talk about this man I
feel like and I'll just put I'll put the
cards on the table mmm my personal
opinion and and maybe this is like
unfair judgment or whatever but I can't
can't help it I feel like you're a
you're a very good musician you write
beautiful songs you obviously love
everything about touring and performing
and the feedback that you get from from
doing it live but I think your gift is
writing and I feel like and please tell
me if I'm way off base on this I feel
like at times perhaps the touring is a
distraction from doing the thing that
scares you which is sitting down and
looking at a blank page
my writing is currently frozen in
carbonite like Han Solo in the Empire
Strikes Back
the I'm glad you yeah we pulled that
back to the Empire Strikes Back for a
call back my book flopped and that was
incredibly painful to me I still it
flopped only in terms of how many people
purchased it yes losses as well as a
work that you're not proud of or that
doesn't have merit so no and then that
and that to me makes it worse which is
that every time I open it and I go back
and look at the book and and I'm like I
did it I really I wrote a great book and
I'm so proud of this and every person
who's ever read it has come up to me
like man I love the book you know and
it's been so meaningful to people and
they come to shows they bring their
copies that are all tattered and you
know that they've brought everywhere
with them and or people buy extra copies
to give to their friends and like the it
has whatever 4.8 stars on Amazon you
know it's been but my publisher did not
represent my interests well and they did
almost nothing to promote the book and
it was lost in the shuffle and I mean
I'll be honest about that was crushing
for me that was incredibly painful and
um and you know and I mean and I did
dude I you know I owe you an apology for
this I feel like at that time in my life
leading up to the book I leveraged every
friendship I had to do everything I
could to get the word out about the book
but that's what you know is it my
optically focused on that you know
apologize to me for that I mean that's
what you have to do you have to be your
own entrepreneur you have to be your own
marketing team and and you know you can
say like well the publisher is supposed
to do all those things but ultimately
that that responsibility falls under
your shoulder so I don't regret you that
at all I wasn't done this is what you
have to you have to get very unabashedly
to put a microphone in front of you I
love the book you know I can't say
enough good things about it if people
are new to this podcast and haven't
checked it out I swear I'll make it up
to you you should all purchase it there
we finally got a placement and now you
know why you're here
but no I mean I love the book man and I
think and I and I hear you and I know
and you know I can only imagine what
that felt like but you know at least
intellectually that the solution to that
is to just start writing the next thing
yeah you know yep and and when you take
that break it gets harder and harder yep
all right so I'm gonna outsource my
motivation which is which is something
I've gotten really good at so we're
gonna we're gonna do this the month of
November I'm gonna write every single
day if you could see his face right now
should we create a hashtag yeah well
we'll come up with a hashtag for your
rights
the and please everybody join me whether
you're a writer you're not a writer like
let's all please right just sit down
turn your phone off for half an hour 45
minutes an hour every day do it every
single day for the month of November and
something will happen right and it's
time I put it yes you're absolutely
right I mean you're calling me out and
thank you and that's why I'm here is to
like because you understand and you get
it yeah and that's exactly what I'm
doing I've been I've been listen I mean
I I also I did it you know I did a live
record that went to number two on iTunes
on the comedy charts you know I mean I
like I have a live show now that is that
did not exist a couple years ago I have
a ton of new songs that all counts but
I'm not writing and that counts too and
I'm and I'm hiding for
makes I'm scared because I feel like I'm
out of [ __ ] I feel like I'm out of ideas
you know and I don't know what the next
thing is and but the only way to solve
that is to begin the process of writing
and it's not about publishers and VOC
agents or what other people think or
sales or any of that it's about your
relationship with yourself and the
written word and I think for you to not
be writing is for you to is is for you
to betray not just the gift but yourself
yeah you're totally right you know I
mean I
I'm guilting a friend of mine into
writing a memoir and one of the things
that I told him is that not everybody
can do what what you can do what we can
do this gift of stringing words together
and having it create meaning or created
create a story or to be able to write a
page and have somebody else read that
and then they can be in the same room
that they that we were in it in our head
feeling what we felt and and even if
it's not inspirational even if it's
incredibly depressing just that
experience helps because for them to
read it they're like oh another person
felt what I felt or there is another
person in the world I need to practice
empathy I need to practice compassion I
need to know that I'm you know that
communicates to us that we're not alone
you know writing shows us that other
people exist you know and that there are
other worlds out there aren't other
lives and yeah I just need to suck it up
and just like I've been licking my
wounds about it for as long as I can and
as time ya know to just try again and
you can't you can't transmit something
you haven't got so you can't try to
convince some friend of yours to write a
memoir or get up in front of students at
Yale and tell them how to do this or
that if you're not doing it yourself
there is an in office inauthenticity to
that and a disconnect that you need to
resolve and it will make you a better
and will make you a better teacher you
know make you a better writer it'll make
you a better servant but I think that
there's some dissonance you know in
yourself right now around this issue and
if you can heal that and resolve it but
I just can
to the page and showing up for it
without without knowing what that's
gonna look like I think that is a huge
also a huge part of your healing process
that goes hand in hand with these other
things that you're doing to be more
gentle to yourself in your health yeah
you're right I mean it's time for I you
know I went out there and like beat
myself up in every regard you know
physically mentally emotionally and like
well I'm fixing my back and fixing the
chronic pain issues that I've had so I
can run again fixing my health like
while I'm on this health kick it makes
sense to to do that for my brain as well
and get back to you know just a just
that little daily workout of you know
putting the nope end of the page for an
hour a day I mean I think that's I don't
know I think I I think it will totally
change I know it'll totally change where
I am in my head if I can do that finally
got really the one of the other things
I've started doing and you'll get a big
kick out of this is that I've been
speaking at high schools about drug and
alcohol abuse yes and and give me that
pitch and how to succeed and how to how
to fail uh-huh
I mean one of the things is that I think
we know now that two to preach
abstinence to kids it's not going to
work because they're smarter than that
and they have access to information they
know that we drank or we partied or you
know we you know abstinence abstinence
based sex education has been proven to
be like a universal fit that's a great
way to have a kid you're 16 yeah I know
and so I just approach it as eight as a
time management thing that all of you
have things to do with your life you
have big things to do whether you want
to be an emcee whether you want to be a
model whether you want to be the
president whether you want to make a
million dollars you want to build apps
you want to build cars yeah you have
stuff to do with your life so when
you're hanging out with your friends and
somebody's like
got a bottle you want to go hang in the
park and drink the bottle just say no I
got stuff to do because you have stuff
to do and whatever you're trying to do
with your life alcohol will be an
obstacle it will absolutely it'll it'll
prevent you from doing whatever it is
you need to do whatever it is you have
to do and you share your own personal
story oh yeah I'm so gonna like get them
to relate to you yeah yeah the tattoos
go a long way with the kids you know
they you know but I I tell them about
you know just how yeah you know I like
couldn't even get a job as a barback
when I was 32 and I was working off
Craigslist and doing you know just about
nothing you know and then now you know I
did 145 shows on the road last year in
five different countries you know I had
a live record come out went to number
two on iTunes I have two more records
I'm working on right now you know one's
almost done the next one will be done a
couple of months I'm an ultra runner you
know I had you know six best-selling
Kindle singles I you know I wrote a good
book none of that would have happened if
I was still drinking now you know we
wouldn't be here now and you know so and
you know and also I tell them to to
embrace their failures you know and and
see that failure is a necessary
ingredient for success you know and that
that and every failure is actually a
step forward you know and then that's
that's how you learn to be who you are
and and what you're gonna do with your
life and failures such a terrible word I
know I know it's you know we got to sort
of like reclaim it somehow but that's
the word that people understand you know
that it's you know I I call it what
feeling forward you know that it's you
know you're not it's not a mistake like
you didn't you didn't do a take wrong
it's it's just a take right you know
it's a try try again you know I like
that I like that I mean usually the
stand-in is learning experience you know
yeah that's still that seems kind of
like weird let's
like well I think that's like
consolation prize yeah well and learning
experience those are two words that
you've heard together so many times that
they start to lose their meaning so I
think you have this sometimes especially
with kids you have to say the same thing
in different language but I'm speaking
to some juvenile offenders in a couple
of days Wow so it's good that we're
doing this I gotta run I of course I
haven't looked at my notes I have to uh
sort of rehearse my pitch and you don't
figure out what it is that's a cool man
that's got to be gratifying and oh it's
awesome I mean the look the most
rewarding thing that I do now is is
teaching and is talking to people you
know and and you realize that that's
service right that's giving back yeah
and and and what is the you know what is
the impact of doing that like being
engaged we you know we talked about
self-obsession
earlier like the best way to transcend
your self-obsession
is to be in that service role whether
it's teaching or getting up in front of
kids or whatever because it gets you
outside yourself and your little
microcosm of problems and all of that
and the feeling that you get in the wake
of that is priceless yeah dude I never
feel more exhausted and more elated than
I do when when I might Yale I'm teaching
because that takes that takes all of my
CPU you know because a lot you know a
lot of times in class it's you know it's
nonfiction writing writing about your
life and so everybody comes with some
trauma that they've survived that
they're trying to use writing as the
tool to work through that trauma to move
forward and that's exactly what you and
I did you know and so I have to you know
sort of Shepherd them through this stuff
and a lot of times it's it's like above
my paygrade
it's you know it's just it's more than
like I don't know the answers I don't
know how to comfort them I don't know
how to guide them and sometimes it's
just like I'm here for you right you
know like it give me an example of that
rape there's you know always a woman or
several women in my class who have you
know endure being raped your job isn't
to be their psychiatrist
your job is to help them figure out how
to translate that that emotion into onto
the page yes absolutely and I do and I
do try to draw a hard line at the you
know in the opening of the class between
like I I'm here to teach you writing and
I'm gonna do my best to teach you
writing but also I'm a human being so
when I see somebody in pain who's
struggling with something I'm all we you
know what I mean I'm always trying to
provide them with the tools to move
forward and there are some things that I
just don't I don't know how to help them
through it you know you know there was a
woman who who lost her son like 20
year-old son to an overdose you know
nothing more unnatural than a parent
losing a child and you know so that's
that's always challenging it's
exhausting I mean after Yale I have to
sleep for like three days just I'm so
fried but it's so good man it's it's a
real privilege to be able to to be in
that position to try and help people do
they let you wear the hotwheels hat when
you teach hell yeah dude I'm I'm the
dirty rock-and-roll teacher like they
would be disappointed if I didn't you
know if I didn't show up and like the
fan falling apart and like blasting Guns
and Roses or whatever no this is like
part of the identity that you're holding
on to right so this this Hot Wheels hat
I think that's a replacement from the
original notice is that the same one
this is the same one from like Zeus you
had that same hat like when I first met
you I don't think I've ever been with
you when you were not wearing the
hotwheels hat it smells like a foot good
it's bad news what is it about that hat
it's my hat but what is it like why that
hat I don't know I just I like the
drummer my old band used to wear hats
like this and I was like oh that's a
good hat I should get one of those and
my hair started to thin and then I was
like all right now I need to rock that
hat all the time but I was like I don't
want to just be one of those guys with
like the generic I was like it's gotta
be a little personalized and I found the
hot wheels patch I got my mom to sew it
on for
and listen you didn't buy that hat you
actually made this is one-of-a-kind dude
all right I have like a little bit more
appreciation for it then yeah so when
you get up an update day one first day
of class at Yale and you get up and and
you know I would imagine you're wearing
a short sleeve shirt you see the tattoos
you got the hot wheels hat on yeah you
are shoes I do wear arts I wear vans I
try to wear jeans as much as I can bear
it you know it's when it's not too hot
it is sort of like Bill Murray didn't
like you know meatballs era Bill Murray
you know teaching a writing course you
know Bill Murray and the Robin Williams
roll in Dead Poets Society yeah yeah
yeah that's good man
well cool dude I think we got a we got
to close it down here awesome
yeah this is good see I knew we had so
it's plenty to talk about why wait a
year and a half it's me it's me as in
yeah I've been busy I mean everywhere
I've been scattered I've been what's
next you going on the road again house
living in Atlanta I mean I'm not really
there much my apartments the [ __ ]
bomb dude it's crazy I have two bedrooms
and two bathrooms it it was like you're
a living miracle it just feels like
miracle surprise just feels like
American opera and you know you've been
with Maddie your girlfriend for two
years now a year and a half something
yeah yeah yeah
it's that the longest relationship
you've ever had sober yeah it's a long
as you live and sober yeah she's the
best she's awesome she's you know she's
really she's full of surprises cool
thanks for doing this man dude thanks so
much for having me back all right
Mishka Shoob all easy to find the
Internet at Mishka Shu Bali Twitter and
Instagram and I swear I'll make it up to
you you got all the Kindle signals you
can find all this and we'll have a
hashtag for the November writing
challenge we should decide that now what
are we gonna do hashtag michiga writes
well it can't be about me it's gotta be
about us it's got RRP rights our RP
rights is that too long but then it nut
is about you do because this is the
challenge to you it's a reminder to you
I think you're doing it as a group thing
but Mishka I just feel it I don't know
dude like now I feel the pressure yeah
dead radio error here I got it out so
you know what wolf will decide off mic
yeah then I'll put it in the intro and
the outro and I'll put it in also notes
I have to i'm should have shown it to
you before - but i have to show it to
you when we get out of here i have the
guitar that was made for me by a ritual
podcast fan Carl Adams in the UK and he
arranged to have this beautiful guitar
made for me with primal roots his
company and it's the it's the elephant I
saw it's a [ __ ] amazing dude it's
gonna blow your mind you didn't bring it
with you it's in the it's in the trunk
of the car I'll show it you were done
here how cool there's a guitar behind
you did you tune that thing yeah it's
almost - do you want to do you want to
take us out with a little something
uh yeah let me get a shot yeah let's do
it
mmm alright so now she is gonna take us
out what's the song called this song is
called you were the song you are the
song peace plants
[Music]
you are the load in the sleepy sound
engineer you're the green room carpet
the stale smell of beer
you're the lingering presence as the son
died in the room you were the drink
tickets
you were the food
[Music]
you were the regular scowling at the
band you were the laughs and bingo
ladies you were the hostile doorman you
were the karaoke bros pass and worn ID
around you were the prettiest girl in
this goddamn one muscle car town
[Applause]
[Music]
you were the words you were the betta
melody the song
[Music]
now you're everywhere now that you're
gone
[Music]
you were the poorly grounded microphone
shock in my mouth
you were the crowd getting restless as
the show headed south
you were the [ __ ] talking trash from
the bathroom line while I was tearing my
[ __ ] heart out in 3/4 time
[Music]
you were the words you were the betta
melody the song
now you're everywhere now that you're
gone
you were the ashtray in a non-smoking
room
you will a check out in the early
afternoon he was something I been
chasing my whole wretched life something
that won't let go of me no matter how
hard I try you are the worse you are the
betta melody the song yeah you are the
words you were the betta melody the song
[Music]
now you're everywhere now that you're
gone now you're everything
now that
you're gone you're everything everywhere
now that you're gone
[Music]
thanks brother another classic